okay last week the commonwealth
secretary general warned cop 26 in
glasgow that if we lose vulnerable
nations who have battled with courage
and resilience we lose the fight against
climate change she warned that if the
gaps on emissions were not closed and
more money was not made available then
many nations risked being subsumed by
rising sea levels and she urged everyone
at cobb to dig deeper and come together
let's find out if she believes everyone
has dug deep enough and i'm now joined
by baroness patricia scotland
um the un secretary general said that
the collective political will isn't
enough to overcome some deep
contradictions and our fragile planet is
hanging by a thread we're knocking on
the door climate catastrophe
was what was agreed yesterday good
enough for
the commonwealth and particularly for
the small islands within it
i think it wasn't good enough but it was
part of the way i mean antonio guterres
was absolutely right we are at code red
and it is deeply worrying that we have
to deep
dig even deeper
the truth is that we are now at 1.1
and if you look at the devastation that
that is causing to many of us we've seen
the effects here in the united kingdom
but look at what's happening to the
small and the vulnerable member states
in our commonwealth we have 32 small
states 25 of them are island states and
many of them are facing this existential
threat now
at
1.1 degrees if you look at what's
happened in sub-saharan africa we have
had double the number of um
droughts floods what does that mean that
means that there are 45 million more
people in southern africa who are
vulnerable to food insecurity that we
have had 45.6
of those who would have had
better food now have substandard food
these are terrible realities the um
representative from the maldives in a
sense reflected some of this
and said that
yesterday's uh decision reflect
really was a death sentence for them i
mean
how could it possibly be acceptable in
that situation well i think it's it's
not acceptable but let's think about
what has happened because you know you
know i'm very much a a cup half full
person so what happened in glasgow
number one we are all agree that 1.5 is
the aspirational target
no one is saying that the science isn't
pointing in that direction for the first
time we have not only governments and
local governments but we've got business
and the scientists and all of us
pointing in the right direction we have
an agreement on methane we have an
agreement that we have to do a lot more
on deforestation we have got an
agreement in relation to how much money
is needed but what has not happened
we haven't got the mechanisms of how to
do it secretary would you just hold that
for a moment we have
some breaking news uh
the queen
has decided it's been announced this
morning that with regret she will not be
attending the remembrance
sunday
ceremonies this morning that is breaking
news that is just coming and we're now
going to talk to rhiannon mills our
royal correspondent who i think is in
whitehall right now
that's right of course there was a huge
amount of anticipation about whether or
not her majesty would be here for a
remembrance sunday on thursday we were
told that she would be attending however
in the last few moments we have had a
statement from buckingham palace
confirming that unfortunately her
majesty will not
be attending the cenotaph today now i
can read you the statement that they've
sent through
which says the queen having sprained her
back has decided this morning with great
regret that she'll not be able to attend
today's remembrance sunday service at
the cenotaph her majesty is disappointed
that she'll miss the service so i think
one thing to point out there is they're
saying that she has sprained her back
also i understand that the back sprain
is unrelated to the recent doctor's
advice that we know that she's had
over the last couple of weeks to rest
it is obviously really unfortunate
timing but this back sprain has happened
very recently and we're also told that
nobody regrets the fact that the queen
can't be here
more than the queen herself she is
deeply disappointed not least because
she regards today as one of the most
significant engagements
of the year and of course that is
because she is a member of that wartime
generation during the second world war
she saw her father rallying
the nation as king and also of course
her husband prince philip who died
earlier this year
served during the second world war
as well
just to
stress though we are hearing that
because of a back sprain the queen will
not be able to attend
the events here today however other
members of her family will still be here
in force in attendance of course in
recent years the queen has handed over
that responsibility of placing a wreath
at the base of the cenotaph on behalf
the nation she's handed that
responsibility to her son and heir the
prince of wales he will again
carry out that duty but just to stress
we will not see the queen here at the
center half today
rhiannon thank you very much indeed for
that announcement uh that the queen will
not be
at the
remembrance day uh ceremonies this
morning um baron in scotland the
commonwealth plays uh a major role in
today's event yourself i think
lay a wreath it will be
um disappointing i think for many of the
veterans absolutely the queen is adored
rightly she has shown total commitment
to the commonwealth and that she is much
loved so an opportunity like this to see
her and to pay homage for what she
herself also did because people do
forget that she was an engineer she was
she was making her contribution as well
so i think there'll be a lot of sadness
but everyone will be wishing her well
everyone will want to see her again and
she is the beating heart of most of the
love that is in the commonwealth so we
do wish her well well i hope that uh
this is just a this is something
temporary it sounds as though it is
precautionary but we will no doubt be
hearing more now um let us return if we
may to the
issues that arose out of yesterday
part of your role uh as
the uh
head of the commonwealth uh secretariat
is to
essentially bring all the members of the
secretary together um
is part of your job of the next year
going to be frankly to stop some of your
members india australia for example
drowning others for example caribbean
island well the most important thing to
remember and the great thing about our
commonwealth is we all sit around the
same table and i know that both
all of our members care desperately
about the small states we're going to
have the next commonwealth
heads of government meeting in kagali
next year climate change is bound to be
at the top of the agenda it's really
important for us to remember trevor that
it was the commonwealth back in 1989
way before cop was ever invented that
said that if we did not address this
matter it would be an existential threat
and the commonwealth is so tired of
being right we want no longer to be
right we want to be able to deliver that
1.5 and i do know that both with india
and australia there is a love and
affection and an appreciation of the
small states and when you sit around
that table eyeball to eyeball it's a
very different
occasion and i think the only place
where that actually happens is round the
commonwealth table and we will be urging
encouraging and depending on our member
states to do what they've always done
and that's to stand in solidarity it's
important to remember that in malta when
our leaders came together
just days before the paris agenda we
came up the commonwealth came up with
two degrees implementation and a 1.5
aspirational target we will be pushing
and pushing hard and i know that our
small states who are literally seeing
this as a death sentence will not go
give up because if they do they'll no
longer be here and we're not willing for
that to happen we will fight secretary
general thank you very much for your
time this morning i hope we'll return to
this uh in months to come thank you
you